mr justice zacaroli is currently
delivering uh his final closing words at
the moment we can tell you though that
he has uh found in favor of ed sheeran
uh within this case ed sheeran was
accused of copying part of the
a shape of you the refrain where it goes
oioi a grime artist called sammy switch
claimed that actually in fact that he'd
written the song two years earlier and
ed sheeran had heard the song uh mr
justice zuckerle has said that he's
allowed ed sheeran's claim in this case
and dismissed uh the sami switch's
counter claim acknowledging that there
are similarities between the two songs
but saying there is he understands that
there is certain differences within the
two songs
he believes that you can also within
that say that the that refrain could
have originated from sources other than
uh sammy switch's song uh
he's the important thing that he is keen
to stress as well was that uh within ed
sheeran he'd been accused of either
unconsciously or consciously copying a
part of the song mr justice zacharelli
in his case has said that he neither
deliberately or subconsciously copied uh
sammy switch's song and he believes that
certainly the ed sheeran hadn't heard
this song so yes it's found in favor of
ed sheeran in this case